okay what I'd like to do is I like to go
ahead and start exacting uh some of the
bills here we know that we're waiting
upon uh amendments coming over on uh 5
30. uh that's a bill which was a
hangover from uh Monday
and 452 which is school building aid
application process in which we put an
amendment forward after the work session
on Friday
so now we're dealing with the bills down
below that uh which would you know so
the first bill I'd like to address just
get us into a friendly mood would be HB
and I'd like to call upon represent
cordelli for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I would move
retaining House Bill 637
is there a second
so we have a motion to retain
Amy we're not going to be doing anything
for a little bit here yeah uh we have a
motion to retain 637 made by
representative cordelli and second by
Adam clerk we're just going to let you
is there a discussion from uh represent
cordelli
um I I think that there have been issues
erased about some of the terminology
and expansion from just High School into
the lower grades
I have been in contact this morning with
the department and they also believe it
could use some additional looking at
um so uh therefore my motion to retain
represent Myler
any further discussion from the
committee
not seeing any uh Madam clerk when
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative Hobson yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Peter now yes representative cortiela
yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Ron yes representative
Hall yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
no bills which we
uh discussed in the other room and uh
what we're going to do in these bills
we're going to allow discussion uh one
person from each party
because we know where we're going
uh so the first one we're going to take
okay 603 uh
is an EFA uh bill of deals deals with
service providers
um
look to representative Lexus for a
motion
I move
hb603 in expedient to legislate
okay representative seconds that so the
motion is made by represent electus and
second by
um representative uh
pedernal yeah
too much snow shoveling yesterday one
and a half inches in a land
that's enough
um so uh remember I said we're gonna
down to about one person's speak on this
uh represent Lucas would you like to
speak to your motion thank you
um there are a number of issues with
this one is being in operation for a
minimum of one year prior to
participation
and that really prevents
um
places with good ideas or people with
good ideas for how to work with
the esa students it prevents them the
opportunity to even get started doing
that
um but bigger than that is being an
approved non-public school education
program
and there are a lot of people who are
tutors and other
programs that are not
um
they're not actually
Schools they're individuals providing
dyslexic you know
teaching for the dyslexic or just
somebody coming in and teaching as I did
for years math
I was not a school I was a tutor but I
was the math teacher for many homeschool
students
so
so basically I see a number and there
are other issues besides that but those
really stand out right off the top so
therefore I recommend it out thank you
thank you uh further discussion
represent Tanner
thank you
I would just like to say that um
you know we're we're trying to put some
guard rails on on what's happening with
all the things that are going on out
there in the EFA world and I I go back
to Croydon where
um all of a sudden they were faced with
the the parents in the community were
faced with Brenda that was sponsored by
the um
State Department of Education
and prenda is led by guides
and the qualification for the guides
are to be 18 years of age or older and
have CPR training
period
um I
I don't know about you but
um that seems awfully awfully weak
to me for
um taxpayer resourced funds
for accountability
so I think these these things that were
offered in this bill
um were to try to put some guard rails
that that at least something had to be
in uh like Apprentice organization had
to be in business for a year I think
that that's not a huge huge
um ask and I think it's not a huge ask
to ask that
other places that are whether they are
schools or they are quotation schools
not only need to comply with all state
and federal anti-discrimination laws but
they need to have meet the health and
safety standards and codes and also the
criminal background checks which I have
pushed on several other bills as well so
I think this is
um a bill that speaks to what what we
feel is necessary for this program to
function and go on thank you thank you
okay with that we're Madam clerk would
you please call the roll the motionless
itl on 603
foreign
yes
representative yes representative Ford
yes representative Belcher yes
representative Hopson yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison no representative wrong no
representative Hall no representative
Balboni no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman Ladd
yes
okay representative Tanner you you
recognized for a motion thank you I'd
like to make a motion of it of OTP
please for this Bill thank you okay
OTP made by representative Tanner and
second by represent Myler
you're done uh is there any uh
opposition wants to speak to that
not seeing Madam clerk would you please
call the roll
police chairman cordelli no
Representative blackis no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative Hopson no representative
McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
pedernal no Representative cortiello no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative rung yes representative
Hall yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
is
all right so I'm assuming that
representative Tanner you will write on
behalf of the OTP and represent leckis
you will write on behalf of the itl
the next bill we're going to do is
similar and so we'll have a similar
structure
and that's a bill that deals with the uh
upon termination of an account the money
immediately goes back to the uh
education trust fund
um that's it and a nutshell
um so with that I'd look to
representative cordelli for a motion
uh yes I move
itl on House Bill 621. is there a second
we have a motion on the floor put forth
by representative cordelli itl and
second by representative Belcher
representative Cardella you recognize
her discussion uh thank you
um I believe that uh parts of this bill
um were Incorporated in a previous Bill
the May to shall for instance
um
I think the problem for many of us
was with the section about students
enrolling in a resident District public
school and the immediate termination of
the EFA and remaining funds being
transferred right back to the education
trust fund and the possibility that
there are outstanding
payments in process
that would be uh problematic if the EFA
further discussion from yes representing
uh Luna sure thank you thank you very
much Mr chair and um and you know unlike
the the last bill in fact unlike all of
the um the the bills with respect to um
education Freedom accounts this is a
bipartisan Bill and um or has bipartisan
sponsorship and um and this bill is
actually word for word the same as a
bill that was um that was introduced uh
by um uh by a member of the Republican
caucus uh two years ago and um and had
um again had in fact it was all
Republican sponsorship on um uh on that
so I'm I'm not quite sure why the
language had um
had uh uh Republican support
last year but but at least in the the
comments leading up to the the exec on
this bill May likely fail to get a
republican support at least in this
committee this year but um but to to
address a couple of the points that
representative cordelli made uh this um
621 does tighten up on the requirement
for um that'd be good the um the private
contractor to refer suspected cases of
misuse of funds to the attorney general
changes the word may to shall yes there
is another bill that does that but the
other Bill still requires the contractor
to determine that the misuse was was uh
was uh with intent which is not
something that the Department of Justice
usually has a contractor do this is
does so it does keep the bar for
substantial misuse that could be defined
in rules but it gets rid of the word
intentional uh which uh which we think
is um is a barrier
to
the state determining
um if if there's been any Mis fraudulent
misuse of funds in this program
so
so that's a that's a key that's a key
different difference and I think a very
uh important uh Improvement to put some
guard rails on on this program uh and
prevent fraud
as far as the as far as the other um
cases yep it certainly tightens up uh
EFA payment Provisions when a student
enrolls is a full-time full-time student
and again language comes completely from
what was presented by um by
representative Hamm uh uh last year so
um so anyway I'm hoping we can you know
see to it and and maybe get some
bipartisan support for this bill by
having some bipartisan support to defeat
the itl motion thank you very much
further discussion of course we've just
had one-on-one so uh Madam clerk are you
ready to call the the motion is OTP on
this is itl
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative Hobson yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative courtiello
yes representative Myler
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
represented Ellison no representative
wrong no representative Hall Nell
representative Balboni no Representative
cascadden no representative Damon no
chairman Ladd yes
108 is 10 days thank you very much now
representative luno you can go your way
all right so we thought we had it last
time but now we're gonna I'd like to uh
make a motion about to pass and so we
have a motion on the floor OTP on 621
made by representative luno and second
by representative miler
okay any discussion from representative
uh cordelli
no no none uh Madam clerk when you're
ready
the motion is OTP on 6 21.
thanks chairman cordelli
no
Representative blackis no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative Hobson no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
Representative cortielo no
representative Myler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative yes representative
Ellison yes representative yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadin yes
representative Damon
yes chairman Ladd no
10 years 10 days
okay representative Luna will write the
OTP and represent cordelli will write
we're trying to get these things done uh
in today too so we can get them to
Lindsay
okay
um
the next bill which I'd like to go to we
did just get uh Jennifer Ford brought
them to us the Amendments for the
amendment for 452.
this is a bill dealing with school
building aid application process so
we're going to hand these things around
here
nothing
does everybody have a copy
foreign
changes in this as you recall on Friday
last week we had a subcommittee working
on uh the whole process in which we
invited in uh doe to that uh looking at
the timeline for submitting applications
right through the through to the in
completing the process when they're
awarded that's been changed and I think
we pretty much went over that even when
we the bill was introduced in hearing
but one of the changes which we had
superintendent Taylor I believe from
Cobra came down and worked with us on
Friday
and that as you recall there are three
school districts receiving School
building a grants in the next biennium
depending upon money being allocated in
that budget and
we hope there is uh the schools
receiving them or uh down in the
Rochester
inadnock and Colebrook not necessarily
in that order but those are the three
and we were discussing uh superintendent
Taylor's District which is Colebrook
and they just recently have had to close
down their High School the old Academy
building was built 100 years ago or so
and it became just plain obsolete to
provide the types of services which are
necessary especially when they're
shipping their students across the river
to Canaan for Career Technical education
and the CTE program over in uh Canaan
although it's providing many fine
programs it's not providing all the
programs necessary in Colebrook and as
you know cobrook's way up North on the
line and a lot of Industry up there
depends upon forestry upon the woods and
diesel mechanics and diesel work on
these vehicles be it a tractor or be it
even a lawnmower and that's one of the
programs they they don't offer across in
Canaan that they want to bring back
across the river to cobra
and so they're looking at also
incorporating CTE within this school
and that's been supported by the
department of education but also
providing the space for the various high
school required courses to be taught
properly where you're trying to do it in
a school which was designed originally
for Apple upper levels of of elementary
school middle school and not for the the
courses that are now required so the new
school is going to be a renovation of
the current did everybody get a copy
do you have a copy of the amendment okay
so what we want to do is ensure that the
Cobra doesn't get knocked off the list
and why they came down here
why superintendent Taylor came here is
that there was an indication that the
three point something million dollars
which they're receiving they've also had
the opportunity to receive a private
grant money to do this from the
charitable people up there over two
million dollars is coming in from one
benefactor
that's that's two-thirds of that whole
cost
but we have in legislation if you look
on page one on lines three and four
funds received from federal grants or
grants from other state programs shall
be subtracted from the total project
costs when Computing grants under this
paragraph that's a change
but the the ability and the what the law
currently says if you get it from
charitable trusts or grants such as that
from private donations that's subtracted
from the amount of the grant
and we all looked at that and said wow
we don't really understand why that's in
there with the charitable trust we
understand the state and the federal
grants things should be taken off but
when it comes to this aspect uh no and
so it was a unanimous recommendation
from the subcommittee to move forward in
in a strike out those four words which
were four or five words which would have
restricted them from using and using the
2 million to uh to disallow the the
amount being subtracted from the Grant
from the state
and secondly there was language in there
which dealt with the school building
authority and some of the
responsibilities of the school building
authority as you know in school building
in statute right now the school building
authority is a group that's comprised of
the State Fire Marshal State Treasurer
the Department of Education and three
other folks uh appointed by the um uh
governor of which uh represent a hill is
the chair of that particular group that
group is really tasked to ensure that in
in the allocation of State dollars out
to various functions or cost is that
there's enough bonding power available
within the local to ensure that the the
match is going to occur the financial
status is strong
and there was language that was put in
here initially to ensure that the
schools receiving this would also have
to uh that would be a responsibility
School building authority The Way It Was
Written it really didn't make much sense
the so the language in your reverts back
to exactly how it was in the past that
they go in and they verify the ranking
that comes to them from the Department
of Education if the ranking is then uh
seen as similar then their report goes
back to do in onto the State Board of
Education for approval if there's a
difference there then there's a process
for hearings which can go on so those
are the changes within this amending
language that also includes the dates in
which you know we must comply in and and
uh looking at uh the applications which
come uh in the past the the school
districts are notified of a grant on
January 15th and that gave very little
time for them to get their warrant
article put together in confirmation
that that you know they it's indicating
that they were would also put on the
article and say they're going after this
uh this grant now is uh released to the
public uh in the preceding school year
by November 15th I believe the date is
and so I give some time for the uh um
mechanics of the school district to
function in terms of uh going forward
with these grants and also allows them
to build a warrant article based upon
um if if contingency upon money being
approved by the local
so that's the nature of this
um of this uh Amendment which we have
which it replaces the entire bill
so
I I'd like to put a motion forward of
OTP on this particular I shouldn't have
done all the discussion before the
motion was put before I apologize trying
to get things done quickly today putting
a horse the cart ahead of the horse uh
so HP 450 452 I hand the gamble over to
you represent cordelli and the next
OTP
OTP is the motion
um is there a second
second second by representative Ford
um I think you have your discussion I
have no further discussion thank you uh
yes representative I have a question let
me just ask representative Ford first
representative Ford did you have
anything dead no representative Cornell
would this be in time for Colebrook to
still get
okay yes we looked into that and that's
correct because the budget's approved at
a certain time and at the same time this
is done so it'd be in place in law that
representative Tanner
thank you I have um just a couple of
questions or one one comment that it
seemed like in a couple of places
there's
um duplication
um for example in section one paragraph
a is then duplicated again down in line
17 18 and 19.
um and there's another spot that as I
was reading and I thought I've already
um I guess what I'm asking is that uh
changed now and it's from from
experience that um
this a couple of the schools that I was
representing in my last term
had where uh the initial
um
the initial
submission of the project uh it seems
like
is not reviewed by anyone else other
than the commissioner and that
um
and there's another spot where uh if if
the emergency projects are are
recommended by the commissioner so the
commissioner seems to be a real big
gatekeeper in this and that's where
they seem to have a bottleneck the last
time they they actually had a lot of
confusion
um
project applications were returned to
them with new updated requirements that
weren't in the original requirements
um and they were very frustrated with
that and I'm just wondering
I see the that you have the
Commissioners the gatekeeper before it
even gets to the State Building Aid uh
Authority and then the State Building
Aid Authority there's an overview by the
school board the state school board for
the ranking I see that kind of division
I'm just wondering if maybe
um
should be considered that there's a more
uh not necessarily oversight but
[Music]
um
looking at it looking at projects
by a few people other than just the
commissioner at the at the very
beginning of the whole process
uh I I can respond to that the the word
Commissioners used in Prior law as well
um it's it's when the commissioner
receives these applications that's
that's when we talk about the department
on grants such as the commissioner
receives but on this particular area
right here the project all the projects
are then reviewed by the by Amy Clark
and and Company
which is Amy Clark and Amy Clark and and
uh uh it's it's and then they're
presented back and they're reviewed by
the department and then they're sent to
the school building authority
um that's the the balance within this
whole process in terms of emergency
projects
um I was part of an emergency project
when our roof was not good at the Middle
School in Haverhill and we were off
cycle we couldn't go through the whole
building application process to ensure
you know all those those steps which are
required we needed the money then and
there because it was a safety issue we
were dealing with mold and everything in
the attic and the roof was ready to cave
in so that's a responsibility of a
commercial the commissioner to and that
those emergency projects are then looked
at by the engineer At Doe they go out
and look at them so
Commissioners use but it's basically
it's it's the department within or the
and I I had just brought to my attention
here that there was another change which
didn't get into this I'm glad Amy's here
today on line 14 on page one beginning
January 1
2025. it's not 23.
yeah this all goes it starts on in in
2025 so I've asked Jen to contact
UM
and across the street here to get that
corrected because we want it that's
that's a you know a two-year change but
that's the way we had it and discussed
it the other day in the work session as
well
represent Myler yeah I was going to
raise the issue the January 1st
is that a new date
Amy do you have a second come up in in
maybe these technical questions
should come from the Department answers
we've had in the past the problem of the
timing of when you've received the
reports Etc so there's time to deal with
this so that they get it into the spring
building cycle Etc so it is the January
1st a new day is foreign can you back
off just take us right through the whole
process because we're backing off at
least a half year on top of what you got
right now right sure um so for the
record my name is Amy Clark with the
Department of Education
um which the school building aid program
falls under my Bureau so just for the
first question is the original language
you had in front of you was July of 2025
and that presents a problem because
later on there's a recommendation of
April they have to submit the
application in April before so it really
has to become effective before July
because I need to submit an application
in April so the work session talked
about changing that to January which is
suitable but it would be January 2025
because we rank the projects
um and so if
so the timeline is being changed in this
for this proposal instead of application
Apple applicants applying a year and a
half in advance so right now
I think the best way to explain this is
if people were applying right now for
building aid for today's for the budget
that you're talking about right now they
currently had to apply last summer and
then they wait and then they're trying
to go to Warren article but they don't
know what the state budget is right now
and it causes a lot of problems for
schools because they have no idea what
the state budget looks like so
this bill pushes it up so if we were
here two years from now and you all are
talking about the state budget those
applicants would be applying now
um and so that when money comes they get
ranked by November and they can go to
their voters with the amount of Aid
um that the state would be available to
them so it doesn't push them back it
actually pushes them forward by several
months uh so if that was what you were
looking for yes go ahead so uh back to
to the issue that representative Tanner
raised
um talk share with us would you how the
process is for review and so the the
application arrives at the department
correct what happens to it so um in the
current law applications come to the
Department of Education in July last
summer we've taken those applications
we've reviewed them for completeness
then the Department of Education my
group I have three of us that go in and
we review the projects we visit all the
schools we rank them according to the
criteria that's in the law and the rules
and then we present that ranking we
score them we present that ranking to
the school building authority in
December then
the school building authority verifies
our ranking make sure that we're doing
the things that we're supposed to be
doing and then they submit that list to
the State Board of Education in January
which would been this last January uh
and then the J the State Board of
Education publishes that list so that
schools know excuse me I should have
some water uh schools should know uh
where they are on the list by January
and then of course they have warrant
articles going on right now uh and
without knowing what the state budget is
they're asking their voters for
something that's really difficult to do
because they don't know how much money
we're going to give them and then the
state budget is approved hopefully by
July 1st okay so just as a follow-up to
comments so it says in here that the
commissioner shall accept so my
presumption is I don't mean to be uh so
specific here but the application
arrives at the department
correct now it goes does it go
immediately it says application for
building Aid doesn't go to immediately
to your desk or does it go to the
commissioner's Nest then to your desk at
what point in time does the commissioner
actually see the rankings and ultimately
gets involved and is it after you guys
your your team has dealt with this right
I mean um yeah so
um with all due respect to our
commissioner
um he's not really involved in the
ranking process it comes to my program
and we rank the projects correct
that's why we have an engineer doing
just like you said they're my key
process do you have your mic on like
representative you said the ranking
process what I've what I was under the
understanding was it was in the
accepting process that there was an
issue
um I'm not sure what applications you're
talking about is there do you want to
um give that information I can answer a
little bit of that what we have in law
right now they have to be accepted but
they're only going to be accepted if
they're complete we don't uh accept
parts of an application that's what Amy
does so they are going to the department
underneath the commissioner's name
saying he's the you know the the
commissioner of that department but
immediately they they funnel directly to
this this person right here who will
then sort through them to make sure they
are complete if they're not complete you
know they're the the district's called
it and said get your act together get
all components all elements filled out
on this thing
um we have you know I have rejected a
couple of applications for
incompleteness um usually they're
egregious like it says we'll we'll
provide information we'll provide
information we'll provide information
um and we can't we're ready to rank our
window is tight they have to be complete
applications per the law
um
that you know they have to be complete
applications but I have rejected a
couple of applications because they have
not been complete again I don't know any
other specifics but yes go ahead is
um the historical nature of the school
building does it have anything to do
with the application or
um the decision whether to to go with it
are you talking about um sorry to sound
ignorant here are you talking about like
historical like meaning the historic
folks like we do do a historic check on
those applications well like for
resources Colebrook or I think you said
was 100 years old and you know some of
these other buildings that are over 100
years old that may have historic do they
need historical
review or whatever it is right they do
um so I want to just make sure that
you're really talking about like um the
historical folks so
um I wish I could remember their names
because they're so important um so
there's an organization at the state
that reviews
um the historical
um components of the building because
that does play a rank a role in ranking
so if your building was so old and they
had some
um resource there whether it was a a
landmark or something then you can get
points for the ranking for preserving
that Landmark but it doesn't if you
don't have anything specific then they
just don't get points for that category
yes represent luno so thank you very
much Mr chair and um Amy I was wondering
if you could uh talk a little bit about
the um the the changes with respect to
the um the school building authority and
also I noticed there's a
um
the amendment deletes um a statutory
reference
um not from yeah I'm just getting this
amendment I mean I was there at the work
session with you all but um so right
where the
right where
the um in the timeline I'm just trying
to find it here
are you talking about on page two around
the amendment yeah it's
it's yes it is right at the right at the
top
um of page two right before the the
reference to August 1st each year
so it's actually sort of at the bottom
the school building authority so line 32
very bottom of the amendment
um where the end of the line goes to the
school building authority it used to say
established pursuant to RSA 195 C
and that part's been removed
um and
the the
it you know I'm not I'm not familiar
with with I mean I was just looking at
the at the text of
198.15c which is the section of law that
this is in but the school building
authority is defined in 195 C so a
and I don't know if there's a another
statutory reference back to 1 195 C or
so is it the reference of 195 C that is
no longer there well in this thing in
the in the bill in 452 on page three
line 22 you've got the reference to RSA
195c
um
along with the first
um refer the first time the school
building authority you know as the
school building authorities sort of
brought into this timeline process
um and then that statutory reference is
removed in the amendment and I was just
wondering if is that was that is there a
reason for deleting that reference or
not that I not that I know of I mean it
may be as good to clarify that the
school building authority is defined in
195c right so the amendment's missing
that
I I if again it's the first time I'm
seeing it so just now um but uh if it
was there before and it's not now uh and
it references 195c 195c is the
definition of the school building
authority and what members are on there
so it probably would be
um good to have it referencing who that
defining who the school building
authority is so so I mean we've got to
the the amendment's going back to OLS
anyway for the effective date right yeah
they could be you know pursuant to 195.
yeah yeah just put just you know just so
nothing I know I've I've talked with
Jeff about that and where it says School
building authority if they get a
definition automatically would reference
back right but there's no harm in
putting in I know that the referencing
that statue it says nothing about school
building Aid within that just it gives
you a definition of what the
responsibilities of the school building
authority are right we hijacked this
terminology we when we initially put
together School building Aid knowing
that we'd like to have a check and
balance in the process and this provides
a check and balance
um we're on the road to you know trying
to look at this whole program which we
do need to do
um uh seeing that the school building
authorities initial
um establishment was not for this
purpose
uh it was for other purposes which are
established back in that that section of
law you're referencing so we were
looking at that time a third-party
organization that existed and the school
building authority has not been very
active over the years at all
um so um we selected it and used it
um so they bring together the treasure
the State Fire Marshal and the
commissioner plus others to do this
review all they're doing basically
looking at did doe file the procedure
that was established with all the
criteria and all that
um and they verify that's all they're
doing it's going almost like in not a
rubber stamp but they're supposed to
ensure that the process was filed and
the school building authority would love
to I know to do either more or even less
uh you know depending upon who's
chairing that organization right now
right but I want to you know I think
it's important that the school building
authority is certainly following its um
uh statutory obligations because they're
they're critical they're critical
um
you know point in the timeline is there
a critical point in the timeline and
they do have a critical Mission which
they're supposed to be doing as well so
I have no objections to pursuant two
yeah being injected yeah I just want to
make sure 195 and 198 are being sort of
connected through this see there was
some concern when we met on Friday that
the language that we had in the uh many
the other previous uh what was the
purpose of the school building authority
people really didn't understand what it
was doing there so we left it supposedly
with the same task which we have to
verify uh evidently the established
person went to what's important well we
took we took out the amendment does take
out the um the verify the the
um the applications
um ability to pay debt
you know the amount of the borrowing
appears to be within the financial means
and available resources of the school
district that's come out right that's
that's also ditto from the school that
the area we're pursuing right we're
seeing pursuant two uh it does say
School District but it says everything
and um let me see if I had any I I mean
I think the I think the big the biggest
change is the one right up front with as
far as um what gets um yeah exactly what
what what gets credited against the uh
the the the state the school building
aid grant so no longer gifts are no
longer credited against that so um so
and uh only federal and state grants
which I think are both are appropriate
to be credited against
State Grant yeah and you can see in the
original bill in line 16 on page one
where it says funds received from
charitable trust bequest gifts insurance
policies that was struck yes result
that's the section which was struck and
then and then another another section to
uh another section as well and I'm
trying to see where it refers
um on
on page three line four
you've got a
uh
that makes a change from
applications with substantial
deficiencies you know that clearly is is
you know
um screened light strained language
um
whether it's referring to Applications
with deficiencies or or facilities with
deficiencies and I think it I think D
corrects that in the amendment
was there anything else that that was
well I think Amy can best you know if
applications if you have the three that
are approved now that leaves 14 other
applications which have not been funded
now you get into another round of
applying
and where do the 14 are they going to be
going forward in that order or if
there's another one all of synthesis
very severe situation can that jump
those other 14 and go to the top because
of the severe that's right yes
and some of that stuff comes out of
building codes and that's why that that
paragraph D I think is so important yeah
and I want to make sure it's still doing
its
so so on my end yes I mean the um the
just right above that is clearly states
that those that were approved on that
November 10th uh 2022 list uh which is
the list of 17 that you keep hearing
about those projects will fall in line
first and then this process will take
place with all the other applicants that
fall behind it so just kind of keeps the
order but currently in Rule and we'll
have to edit our rules to address a lot
of these timeline changes but we
currently the way you jump people in
line you can jump people in line but you
have to meet a higher Life Safety
conditions you have to meet more than
half of the points plus you also have to
have higher points than the people that
you jump so there is there wills and
probably should still be a way to jump
those that are in line uh and also
um this Authority allowing us to
continue to rule make could further
Define what those emergency projects are
I think representative Tanner was
talking about earlier to more clearly
Define what is considered a emergency
project and the Department of Education
right now uses emergency projects that
are like defined in the public school
infrastructure fund is a clear
definition set the State Fire Marshal
office uses as imminent danger and
Life's a substantial Life Safety risks
so there's already definitions in fire
code that talk about an emergency it's
not an emergency because of
um
because your windows have are you know
are not well insulated you know it's
really very specific life safety danger
issues
okay we're not going to be able to
really go much farther with it until we
yes please pursuant to the chapter
law
and then 2025 rather than 23
yes yes the primary reason why we'd like
to see this thing go through is the
timeline the time right now is just too
much of a pinch on school districts as
well as trying to review these
applications and we're not giving the
department adequate time to really
review properly
and there's a lot more we got to do with
school bowling a there's a huge amount
that we have to work on in terms of you
know some conceptual things you might be
considering as that
we have a number of projects which are
three million dollars and less or
thereabouts
we have some projects which are huge
dollars and they can suck everything out
of what we appropriate in one given year
and there's no no way we're going to
ever get to the other 14 projects
and so there's been discussion whether
we should have several different pots
available for the renovation maybe
smaller amounts of reservation maybe
even through the public school
infrastructure fund as a separate pot
where we've had upwards to 40.3 million
dollars in that fund it if you total all
the money we spent
so there all these issues have to be
discussed there's a lot more to it but
it's the feeling of the department I'm
not going to speak for Amy but I've
heard over and over the timeline has to
be changed and that's the primary goal
of this right here
so what we'll do is we'll try it wait
until that comes in
um
uh looking at the other bills which we
you still haven't gotten anything back
we'll talk about 6 40.
yeah we we had some we had called the
department someone
um
Lisa who was uh here and provided
testimony during that okay okay so okay
now we do have uh 354 still also
um
I know we have differing positions on
that but uh maybe what we can do is take
advantage of the moment right here and
have some discussion on 354 without
putting something on on the table here
for action
and so that's what I'd like to do is
jump to that this is um
similar topic appropriating School
building support for Charter Public
Schools
um we have
I believe it's somewhere around two
charter schools which are owned by the
charter school
um so those would be eligible for uh Aid
based upon the 30 percent that we but
there's some that we have in the school
building uh construction side here but
there's also other issues uh which we
have to address on that
um they are a public school they are
dreadfully in need of fundings to
support
um but there's also the issues that's
sort of affiliated with the school
building authority is tasked to do
that's also with the
um the charter school so I'm just going
let's just discuss this a little bit
more representative Tanner
thank you um thank you I don't I I would
wonder how this actually
um is affected or Not by the fact that
we've been talking about the dissolution
of charter schools and some of the
issues with that if they're incurring
debt
um through this building Aid
um and we've talked about I there's
another bill that that we've reviewed
about
um working with the dissolution of
property of just how
if a charter school incurs that how that
when if if and when they have to just
dissolve how that actually is
accomplished and and what kind of
problems might occur with building Aid
on that
that's that's a good topic to be
discussing with this uh we do know that
in if it's a school district that takes
the building Aid and then decides to
close the building down five years after
they've taken that they're responsible
for paying every nickel and dime and
Penny back
uh to the state that they received in
school building Aid they have to have it
in place for 20 years
and and and then if they close it down
in the 21st year they don't of course
if the bond stayed off
so in terms of a Charter Public School
that's an issue which you know has the
need for discussion
represent miler
thank you Mr chair yeah I think I think
this uh bill is premature uh
because of some of the things
representative Tanner to talk about but
the whole issue of the dissolution and
there's also a question of what the
status of building Aid is in general
now we don't know where that's going to
go and so it was it would seem to me
um
that we should
you know I'm not into italing this but
to at least retain the bill
and put it into the whole group that
we're dealing with when we start talking
about Charter Schools when we look at
the uh the disposition of charter
schools if they should happen to close
Etc so
to deal this in isolation
I think is a mistake and it needs to
have more con consideration particularly
as it relates to how does this relate
how does this fit into all the other
requests that we've had I mean we had I
think Amy said we had like 15 17 bills
this or 17 requests this last year and
we only could fund three
um so
um it just seems to me Mr chair this is
a bit premature and that we if we can
just hold this and put this into the
conversation as we deal with the other
issues that we're dealing with Charter
Schools as far as their stability and
where they're going to go forward and
again I I as I mentioned there are some
questions where building age is in
general and so to pass this without that
knowledge it seems to me to be premature
thank you
further discussion yes representative
luno yeah thank you very much Mr chair
yeah I I um I agree with what's been
been said on this I mean I I don't think
um I think I
don't think itl is a good message to
send on this I think retain is that
would actually be a very strong message
to send on it that that this committee
takes takes this matter very seriously
and wants to look into it because you
know I think from from from what we've
um from what we've learned over the
years too is that um Charter Public
Schools and and and public schools don't
necessarily operate on the same the same
way they don't necessarily operate on
the same timeline they they certainly
have very different
um governing
um governance to them school board
versus a a board of directors and um
where's your original and I I
and obviously a school District by
virtue of its um uh you know taxing
Authority has has a different
um you know
different ways to stabilize revenues
that um and and and meet obligations
different than um than than Charter
Schools
um
and I guess in in addition I'm not even
sure that the um that the provisions
that are in uh house bill 452
which of course rewrite substantial
sections of 354. our um are necessarily
adaptable to to Charter Schools uh the
way they the way they apply to um to
public schools so so I you know I'm I'm
I'm not against uh you know responsible
way of of the state funding Charter
School building uh projects but I think
we've got to look at it from a from you
know how applicable is it for charter
schools so the timeline the process and
and you know if we can get 452 which
again is this exact same section Aloft
uh
up and uh and running as this moratorium
is finally being lifted
um and we can we can get cracking on
that and then and then work out some of
the I think the concerns that
representative Tanner and Miler you know
talked about with respect to Charter
dissolution uh and responsibilities
there that um that that we could get
something you know meaningful put in
this place so you know I'm hoping the
committee would would come along with
action
yes representative
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
highlight that I think the biggest
utility that I can see of this kind of
program is that
when a when a traditional Public School
has more students coming in it
automatically has the money to do what's
necessary to accommodate those students
but when I charter school they want more
students to come in because they're
successful well they still can only take
so many because they're kind of hampered
by their ability to expand in this
manner so I would see this as the
ability for a successful Charter School
successful being measured by obviously
the parents continuing to send their
children there to be able to expand to
accommodate more students that way the
lotteries can become a little bit more
of a fair mechanism more people can come
representative
I just had a question
um in the governor's budget in the
one-time money did he put money in
towards this towards
building aid for Charter Public Schools
I put building Aid in for all schools
all schools and he increased it to 75
million dollars which paralleled that
which we had approved here we had proved
a bill where we appropriate 50 million
dollars on top of the debt and the debt
for each year of the upcoming biennium
is approximately 25 million dollars each
rounded off
uh we're very close so that comes up to
the 75 million dollars per year
so that's that was put in a very similar
type language just written a little
differently but no it wasn't earmarked
for Charters or for you know this is all
School building Aid okay and the issue
that we're looking at right now is that
we basically
um through the department have already
it's not appropriated but allocated
tentatively that money towards those
projects and those projects as you see
on that 17 list I have a price tag
Associated but that may not be the price
tag according to what I hear from Amy
Clark that they look more specifically
at these and it may you know if they're
not really if they're going Beyond some
of the areas within building something
larger than they have to on the minimum
standards it'll be lesser money received
so there may be even there might could
hypothetically be some left over to
fund not maybe the full hole of a next
project but some School District in that
list of 17 remaining 14 may choose to
take you know a million and a half
dollars first waiting for their three
million dollar Grant maybe sometime in
the future coming by either way
yeah
um so it wouldn't actually change the
timeline that a
Charter Public School could get money if
retaining won't impact the money's not
there right and it's not going to be
allocated until what uh we have January
uh where the applications start coming
in but we're still we're still in what
what fiscal year are we in and what part
of the biennium are we in at that time
we're still dealing with monies that we
have we're doing right now that we
haven't even approved yet in hb1
so uh there is plenty of time
for a retention to occur because it's
not going to make any difference in
terms of uh providing that money to the
the charter schools
or any other schools for that matter
thank you yeah
yeah represent my way just to pick up on
a point that representative Lino made
and one of the things the committee
hasn't looked at we've not had anybody
come from a charter school to say okay
we want to build something
they haven't shared with us about what
the process they're going to use to get
the resources to do the building
I mean as this this is this is a whole
new territory for this committee and we
just haven't had an opportunity to
really look at the sources of revenue
that one might clearly individual
contributions that would come in is one
source that they could get for some
construction costs but we have a look to
see we haven't even heard Bankers for
example how would the banks deal with uh
a charter school that has X number of
students they're going to look at their
all of the revenue sources they have Etc
but we haven't we haven't had a chance
to see oh this is how you can do it
I mean it may be clear to some folks
around the table a service hack isn't
clear to me on how that might happen so
that they've got a foundation that's uh
secure enough that's going to be able to
deal with the loan along with whatever
the state might so that's why I'm I
guess I'm I'm talking myself more here
about the need to retain it because
there's just so many questions out there
before you actually say go forward with
this so uh I would hope you would look
at that too thank you
represent cordelli thank you
um I have been working a little bit with
a charter school up uh in our area north
star Charter that's been approved
um by the state board
and they are in the process of buying
the Old Courthouse in Ossipee
um New Hampshire from the county which
currently owns it has had been turned
over to the local Historical Society for
many years they did not do much with the
building
um
and so it is in need of repair the plan
of the charter school
um
well the there I believe were the only
bid for the building
um
it it is now being reviewed by county
legal department as I recall
um and uh the intent of the charter
school is to they they've had
um contractor looking at the building to
see the extent of the renovations that
are required
um
and their intent is to take out a
mortgage and that is factored into their
um their budget the amount of the uh
anticipated mortgage
um but I I think the uh status right now
is waiting on Final uh County approval
further discussion
yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair representative
cordelli could I just inquire the school
that you were just referencing is it
currently operating in some other
follow up
um so I'm just wondering what if
anything is known in that process so far
um about how they will get a mortgage I
mean how will a bank review their
um I I don't have all those details
I think is the best answer I can give
you
okay we've had a discussion on this
we're really there's nothing on the
table and what I'm going to do is going
to take a short break here uh we have
received them in the back here and I
want to hand that out and see if it
reflects what we had discussed earlier
this morning
so let's take a break for about 10
minutes here please and I think this
does
would everybody please take your seats
okay we have before us a bill here it's
the last one on the docket for today
it's not the last one we're gonna be
acting obviously we've had skip a couple
uh hb640 as an act relative to cost
recovery for Vocational Rehabilitation
programs and there were there was some
question that we had uh regarding trying
to get a better understanding of why
this is before us
um uh why you know what has to be done
is something that's being proposed by
the department and
welcome Miss Hass right h-a-s-s h-a-t-d
okay okay
well welcome Tao said thank you
uh so we have some questions regarding
this bill uh it says the bill repeals
the state right to recover the cost of
vocational rehabilitation services from
an individual who receives a third party
settlement or benefit award can you
please explain
what what brought this all about and
anything else that can help us you know
move forward one way or the other
absolutely
um
Rehabilitation director with the
Department of Education
oh if it's red I'm like red Red's got to
be off but not not in our world right
sorry um I'm Lisa Henson hats the
director for Vocational Rehabilitation
with the Department of Education
um this was a bill that um the
department had wanted to uh move forward
we had done some sort of updating of our
Statute in 21 in 2021 and this was a
part that we simply missed and what this
part um spoke to in the old days
um probably in the 80s and 90s before
the workers compensation system changed
in New Hampshire
if an individual received a workers comp
settlement
um then if they had been working with
Vocational Rehabilitation with the state
we could collect what we had spent on
their case from that settlement
and we this is not something that has
been utilized at all um as at least in
the last 15 years since I've been in
leadership positions within the agency
um
and the workers compensation system has
changed they have their own Vocational
Rehabilitation team over there that work
on anything that that has to do with a
settlement
um so so this was for us to really
repeal this from our statute so that
um you know there's no need for us to be
uh
you know the since they don't come to us
in that manner anymore or haven't for a
long time we didn't feel that we needed
this section in the statute anymore okay
uh any questions from committee members
regarding this
yes represent Cornell just so if
somebody gets a settlement and you have
been working with them you don't try to
get the money back that's correct okay
yeah yeah and and I will say just uh for
the record you know Vocational
Rehabilitation works with uh primarily
individuals that are well below
um a lot of the poverty levels a lot of
individuals on Social Security benefits
um we and again since since the
Department of Labor has their own
workers comp section anything that might
happen
um that they're getting Services right
there within their system so we would
not ask for any
are there further questions from the
committee members
yes represent Damon thank you Mr chair
so
just to clarify what I think you just
said
more of these individuals are serviced
through the Departments of labor than
through doe
um that's right if it would have to do
with any kind of a settlement and I did
check in with their attorneys before you
know we brought this forward uh and they
said that that you know this is it's
perfectly rational to repeal this given
the work that they do in their
Department
thank you yeah represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair that makes some sense
the way you explained it but it seems to
me that there might be another side to
this as well which is
if somebody were injured and they had to
go through these services and they
receive a third party settlement safe
from a lawsuit against some company
Corporation or whatever else right
usually part of a settlement in an
injury case is covering the cost of
medical treatment and whatnot so would
this not be Shifting the burden for
money that they received in a settlement
for that
so let me give you an example of how our
financial financial needs test works
because I think this might answer your
question representative so
Vocational Rehabilitation provides let's
say two different kinds of services
services that are covered by Financial
need where we have to look at someone's
Financial need and then there are
services like job development and
placement that you would say naturally
well why would someone have to pay for
that right that's that's a core service
that we provide
things that would be covered and we
would have to look at someone's
Financial need include things that are
tangible it could be a vehicle
modification that we do it could be a
computer that we purchase for college if
someone so what happens is and this goes
for any customer regardless of if they
had any kind of settlement or anything
if they have a service that requires
financial needs assessment we do that
and so they would say you know I have
this amount of money in my saving would
never ask anyone to you know to touch we
really just look at liquid assets
uh and and let's say they agree okay I
can pay 500 of that computer because I
have some resources we would never ask
for any larger an amount just because
someone had received some kind of a
settlement it's all based on that
Financial need and whether the service
would be a part of it or not
so I don't know if that helps clarify
what you're saying so they may have
received a settlement and it may be a
part of their assets but just because
they have
that doesn't mean we would ask for
well if I may just just so I understand
I want to make sure I really understand
that that part would it be possible
would there be any scenario
where somebody could be
injured on the job all hurt themselves
let's say they go in and they receive a
you know they there's a lawsuit and they
receive a a million dollar settlement on
it and they've received Services let's
say the state spent ten thousand dollars
helping through this process under those
circumstances if we repeal this law the
state could not then go and
ask or require that from that million
dollar settlement part of which would
have been incorporating these costs we
couldn't we couldn't then look this to
receive that back to then be able to
provide that service to another person
down the road yeah so
um
I think to clarify
if we looked at their assets and they
had a million dollars in there we would
say that you have enough resources to
pay for that service let's say it's the
computer for twenty five hundred dollars
um and it was bound by financial needs
assessments so we had to look at their
assets
um so we we would at that point say you
do have the resource to pay for this
um in the case of let's say if it's a
hearing aid what our policy says is that
we have to look at financial needs and
that we could pay up to 50 of hearing
aids
so if again that's Bound by financial
needs assessment
we would look at their resources and say
again you have the resources to pay for
this so we're going to ask you to pay
for this so that we wouldn't like you
said be turning that onto the taxpayers
to pay when they do in fact have the
resources so it's it's it's
um it's not just a factor of the
settlement it's a factor of the service
that they're receiving whether it's
tangible or something like job
development placement and follow-up
which is done by individuals right it's
done by counselors it's done by
Community program providers
um
so it's really based on that Financial
need so if we saw a large amount
you know we would we would ask them to
pay for that because we'll say you know
why can't you if it's liquid assets
again if it's locked up in in yeah yeah
yes Japan real quick
um because the way I'm looking at this
is typically somebody's going to be
receiving these Services
relatively soon after an injury they
will they will seek out these things but
a settlement from a lawsuit often takes
years right to achieve so we would this
would be a situation where you you would
never and is that always been the policy
of the department that they would never
go back to look yeah yeah because
um once people are successful and find
employment we close the case and we
don't you know unless they come back for
additional Services
um which they can you know we're not a
one and done kind of program
um we would never go back and ask for
anything back thank you yeah yeah strip
Santa Tanner
thank you
um who did who is your clientele and and
what kind of interplay do you have with
like HHS
um is it just children that you work
with or a young adults up to 22 or
something so uh Vocational
Rehabilitation is a state and federal
program we work with individuals from
age 14.
um there's really no no high level we've
worked with 85 and 90 year olds in our
services for blind division impaired
unit
um uh we you know we do have a high
interest in working with students with
disabilities but our customers are
individuals with any kind of a
disability you could imagine it could be
a mental health disability it could be a
developmental disability developmental
or cognitive disability we work very
closely with Health and Human Services
we work with the Bureau of mental health
services and we also work with the
Bureau of Developmental Services the the
DD Council the developmental
disabilities Council so we're very uh
we're we collaborate very highly with
those programs as well as the local area
agencies that we have in the state and
the mental health centers that's where a
lot of our referrals come from in fact
are those individuals that are working
in in Medicaid services and and they
don't necessarily pay for job
development and placement College
tuition those kinds of things
um so that's where we can take over and
we can provide any service short of
catastrophic surgeries so you know we
could pay for work boots for somebody to
go and do an internship we could pay for
college we could pay for
um you know uh a screen for someone so
that they can
um they call it a CCTV you know to blow
up the the words for them magnify it so
it's a it's a great program again a
state federal program we are 80
federally funded and 20 state funded and
we have to meet that minimum match to
receive our our full Federal award
total budgets about 16 million a year
so
hopefully that helps give some
background
this representative
so I just want to make sure I understand
if we pass this
the effect will basically be nothing
right
yeah I would I would say that that is
true because
this hasn't really been active if you
will
um it it hasn't been and I think it's
because the workers compensation system
changed
so we didn't have that
um
that collaboration that we have with
them prior which I think was in the 80s
I wasn't here at that time but I'm
pretty sure that's when it happened
um for anyone that that was around Doris
LaChance was the person that we
connected with back in those days but I
don't
to me you know Vocational Rehabilitation
has plenty of resources to assist all of
our customers like I said if they are
receiving a service that requires us
look at financial needs we do that so
that the taxpayer doesn't have to pay
additional
funds you know just because
we're at the point right now where I'd
like to go ahead some of us have a
meeting that started five minutes ago so
I'd like to call upon get a motion here
for this particular bill
um representative perimel do you have a
represent Meyer seconds that motion
further discussion from the maker of the
motion
representative thank you any from the
committee
okay Madam clerk so we have a motion on
the table made by representative
paranell second by representative Myler
uh as OTP for HP 640 would cost recovery
for Vocational Rehabilitation programs
Vice chairman cordelli he's absent okay
uh representative lapis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher
no
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes
representative Peter now yes
Representative cortiello no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Ellison yes
representative wrong yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
17 years two Nays thank you very much
consent thank you Ms hatz thank you very
much appreciate you coming over from Doe
uh we're gonna take a break now and
we're going to be out for lunch here for
thank you
okay
well we can even be here
right here
[Music]
foreign
we have three bills left
so with that um
first one I am looking right here is
452. so let's uh take some action on 452
one way the other right now
um this particular bill
um as we've discussed for uh deals with
the
um
School building aid application process
extending the timeline Etc so at this
point in time I'm going to hand the Gap
over to representative cordelli
thank you Mr chairman and I call on the
chairman for a motion yes I'd like to
recommend OTP on 452.
thank you Mr is there a second thank you
second from representative Ford
um the discussion representative lad yes
I'd like to move uh the amendment to 452
representative Belcher seconds
uh discussion of the amendment yes uh we
had a discussion earlier today on this
bill and there were several areas which
we noted that needed and required change
one of those is on page one on line 14
which changed the date from
2023 to 2025.
so that's now Incorporated in here the
other was on the top of page two
which dealt with the school building
authority and
you can't be kidding me
it's no effective data
is replacing section one but it doesn't
well is it because that's the amendment
and it doesn't it uses the one that's in
into January 1st 2025.
okay so so we got the date right in page
two one
then we also have the change regarding
the school building authority pursuant
to RSA 195c
in there
and those were the two changes we spoke
to earlier today as we've gone through
the remainder of it with uh Amy Clark
so that's all I have to say
uh further discussion representative
Belcher or anything
seeing none was there a second on the
representative Belcher oh yeah that's
go ahead so uh Madam clerk uh take a
roll call vote on the amendment
Vice chairman cardelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yeah representative Belcher yes
representative Hobson
yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative cortiello
yes representative miler
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative wrong yes representative
Hall yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
yes
further motion yes uh thank you uh
representative cordelli I'd like to move
ought to pass as amended HP 452 and the
a second
reps representative Miler seconds
any further discussion representative
I'd just like to say several words here
um this is not going to be the entire
fix for school building Aid this is a
step forward and it makes what we have
better it gives a timeline it also
provides folks like uh superintendent
Taylor the opportunity to go forward
with her uh School building Aid project
that I hope that they receive here
um if if you know depending upon how we
fund things here and I think we should
at least get 50 million bucks per year
and
so it is a good move forward uh I would
like to continue this committee to
continue working with Amy Clark and
those that are involved with school
building Aid to even strengthen this and
to deal with all the other issues
associated with that we know that are
representative anything no thank you any
Mr cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative Hobson yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative paternal
yes representative quartz yellow yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes are the Ellison
yes representative wrong yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes it was consent
okay the thank you very much Amy for all
the work you've helped us out with
the next bill we had to deal with is 5
30 that's the Cooperative withdrawal
built
um we should have an amendment in front
okay
is is the one that everybody got here uh
10198 to make sure I'm looking at the
right one right okay good
okay I'll hand that off to you too
there's some cornelli uh thank you
representative lad would you like to
make a motion on this I'd like to make a
sorry second representative miler
uh discussion further
I think we got it right this time
this would be the third try today
yeah third time's the charm uh it has
the process for
um a district that may want to withdraw
uh working in conjunction with the
Cooperative board as a whole where you
need the Three-Fifths majority vote of
both sides to attain that desired end
so I and as I read it quickly here it
looks like that is exactly what we have
in front of us
and
um I'd like to also thank bear Christina
for helping us get through this process
he was like the the third party that had
to come in
and and and get this thing squared away
we're going to Myler I think we've
talked about this a lot yeah
any discussion from the committee
uh representative Lakers
does this
this appears to be identical to the bill
the way it started except for maybe
I believe that uh Roman 1 and Roman 2
um are revised in this amendment does it
do anything different or is it just
clearer
it it makes the process clearer and that
Roman 1
um says that uh if the withdrawing
District does not vote to withdraw then
but the effect is identical it's just
the effect is uh identical yes
Roman 3
um I think is the the major piece of
this that super majority vote so then
this still does nothing for the small
towns who are stuck because they keep
getting outvoted
well I I
think Roman 3 Roman 3 uh does provide
some assistance so that if they have a
three-fifths vote in the withdrawing
District
um unless there's a three-fifth super
majority also in the entire Co-op they
can withdraw but we ran the numbers and
the small districts it doesn't work
there's enough in the major
we ran the numbers based on the last
vote and
this would have done nothing for them
that might be the case in some districts
depending on size of who wants to
withdraw and Etc thank you
president Belcher thank you Mr chairman
um I I had a question because the we had
a bit of a hysterical issue with a with
a gum Palma in the in the issues on the
other day but it would appear that the
comma is in the same location
um in this bill that caused some
confusion previously I'm looking for it
now it is uh
yeah line twenty
really see that previously
yes
I don't shoot a long time I know
oh is it is it not uh apologies I
withdraw that one
um but I did want to also add just
briefly because I think the point of
trying to do this and I I can appreciate
the concept that we want to balance
these things
but I think ultimately because of the
incentives and the way that it works
when things become out of balance in
these these agreements that these towns
go into the worst the worse it becomes
for one town the more incentivized the
other towns become to keep them in that
District so I think if we want to look
to help these small towns ultimately be
able to go back to the negotiating table
I think they need to have
um
the unilateral determination ultimately
by a by a super majority vote that can't
be overridden
new representative lead
this again like the previous Bill we
looked at is a part of the puzzle
uh to me the larger issue associated
with all this are the articles of
agreement
which are 60 years old in many cases or
in a couple cases they don't even exist
and if we're ever going to be able to
really do something which is
going to be I think most helpful to the
local districts that are part of a co-op
is to require that these articles of
agreement come up for renewal
every X number of years some districts
have that in place for example we talk
about Bridgewater earlier this year
they do have a renegotiating uh no
negotiations of their article agreement
and there's there's an item within those
articles which states that if the
financial Arrangement I.E the the the
the per pupil pop uh tuition payment
being a combination of both daily
membership
and maybe property valuation
theirs is based there entirely on
population
now if that District tries to change
that to 50 of both
they have to do so in consent with
Bridgewater because it's in those
articles of agreement that they agreed
to it the last five years that those
those articles are changed without our
approval we're out of that Co-op
and so there's how things are going to
happen if there to answer your question
about where how do we help those smaller
districts if the districts start writing
these agreements such that it's going to
provide that escape clause or that
ability to
change the articles in conjunction with
you know the population shifts which are
going on or the property valuations like
up there in Carroll right now where the
the property value is really really high
poverty rate is also really really high
so those those are things that have to
be accounted for so I think that and
when we look at this in future and this
is not over there's a lot to it
representation at large not at large all
these issues of membership those have to
be addressed and so as representative
Grenier did years ago he looked at a
component of it this is a component of
it but we now have to really it sounds
like we have a group that's really
interested in doing that I would suggest
during the next you know now next year
here that we're working on this and have
the opportunity to have groups that we
delve into it get all those articles or
agreement in again start looking at it
and saying how can we help
and to move forward I won't
representative Lucas
I guess my concern
this and with what you were saying is
for them to get those new agreements in
um
they have to have a say other than
for instance Carol has gone many times
and asked for a renegotiation and
they've been told no well of course
they've been told no because
they know they can be out voted each
time right and with this three-fifths
they were out voted by that much and to
me the idea of taking the Three-Fifths
out and saying they can leave with a
three-fifths on their own
now the other people have to sit down at
the table and say okay because they know
they can leave so what can we do and
maybe instead of 60 40 maybe they will
agree to 50 50. maybe there'll be I just
see them as being more willing to
negotiate right now when they have that
big of a majority they don't have to
negotiate they don't have to agree to
the new bylaws if new bylaws come up
I I can't see that that we're helping
the little guys at all
right I'll just do a quick one the the
whole uh language and I thought the
language but this concept of a two-third
super majority did not come from people
on this committee here it came from the
field it came from a small Cooperative a
so
further discussion
yes yes it is yes it is yes right
no no
okay it's OTP
all right I don't usually do the no you
don't have a vote right now until
we you have the motion put forward the
second discussion introduction of this
we did right yeah have you introduced
yeah yeah it was moving second
well the clerk would know that's what
actually yeah it was just the bill that
so yeah that's what I have I just want
to make sure because we're talking about
the amendment so I was a little confused
so so I'll take the caval back and you
can make the motion
so at this point in time uh I look for a
motion
yes I'd like to move a lot to pass on
amendment is one zero one nine h
m
we have a motion made by representative
cordelli and second by representative
Miler on
1019h amendment 2 HB 530.
any further discussion for the maker of
the motion none
second yeah
from the committee
Madam Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes
Representative blackis no
representative Ford yes
representative Belcher
yes
representative Hobson yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Peter now yes
representative courtiello yes
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes president yes
representative Ellison yes
representative around yes representative
Hall yes representative balcony yes
representative cascadin yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
represent Cordell you're recognized for
a motion
uh thank you I'd like to move ought to
we have a motion made by representative
cordelli and second by representative
Miler to approve HP 530 as amended with
1019h
further discussion from either the maker
in the second further discussion from
the committee
not seeing Madame cook
please chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative Hopson yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Peter now yes representative Corey
Taylor yes representative Myler
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative wrong yes representative
Hall yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
is that good for consent yeah
um the next bill which we have let's
take about I don't think we've had a
chance to really caucus on this one and
I like to have a moment here
so uh we have this one build app this is
uh 354 Charter School eligibility for
school building a
so we're going to caucus on that there I
don't believe there's any amendments are
there any amendments on that bill
I think so we're just dealing with the
as introduced okay we'll we'll take a
very short caucus here and hopefully we
get back
soon
right
452 450. no wait a minute we just did
foreign
the the uh Bill we're dealing with is
HP 354 Charter School eligibility School
building Aid I like to call upon
I move we uh retained
is there a second
further discussion from the make of the
motion or the second
uh
I think we talked through this pretty
well but it gets down to the point where
it's pretty obvious to all of us that
this needs more study and until we have
more facts and more uh questions
answered about how this might work out
and who might be impacted in which way
and who finally is the recipient if this
does occur uh I think we need to set
that worked out in considerable detail
before we can make it a legitimate
decision
represent Belcher you you are the second
thank you Mr chair yes I I think just to
you know to follow on that I think we
had a few small things we need to look
at things like local school board
um issues with this and I think I think
it would be worth you know taking a real
hard look at this maybe getting a little
study committee or something like that
together and um seeing if we can't
further discussion
um
I I'd like to Echo the the need for a
retain
um this is just a it's uh really an
extension of our school building aid
program
but also one that's very important
um and the Charter Public Schools their
their uh a form of public education has
been around now for a while
we know there may be a couple of them
that are owning their own buildings
right now uh and looking at the charter
school law uh there's uh several error
issues that if something happens and the
trustees give it up and it's now going
into uh default or into a fiscal
situation which they can't afford then
is the resident District going to have
to pick up the the the debt on this
um or how's that going to be handled and
does the school building Aid money
that's been used for the upgrades come
back to the state if it's available how
do you get that and there's a lot of
other issues criteria
um
541a ruler making to establish what
we've done for the school building a and
even within School building aid program
now we know that there are a lot of
issues which need resolution and I see
this as a vehicle for us to do both
look at our total formula and they'll
look at how we integrate charter schools
into that formula I am certainly a
proponent of charter schools but when it
gets to the school buildings I think we
have to be very careful how we we move
forward
further discussion
not seeing anything we have a motion on
the table Madam clerk the motion is to
retain this bill HB 354.
Vice chairman cordelli no
yes
representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative Hopson
yes representative McDonald no
representative Noble yes
representative pedernal
no
representative yes representative Miler
yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Ron yes representative
Hall yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
17 years three days
his app bill is retained
there will be a committee appointed the
way this works is that
if you talk to our our clerk here in the
house they we do set up subcommittees
but we don't like to get a lot of
subcommittees going prior to you're
getting are unloading all the Senate
bills which might come at us this
committee doesn't have a whole lot of
Senate bills coming at us I understand
it's either 20 or less and that's a
piece of cake for us and so um I think
we'll be able to get a subcommittee
going uh quickly other words and uh I'd
be really interested in knowing if there
are folks which like to be on that it's
something that I think we could really
come out with some positive uh results
uh by the the middle of the Fall so we
can get legislation proposed to move
forward with something which might be
taking in account some of the cause and
effect that we might have if we had put
this thing forward right now so
um if anybody's interested please let me
know or let them who's ranking uh
representative and and we'll try and get
this thing going as soon as we can in
the past when we've had committees like
this I've spoken to leadership and we
have had permission to move forward on a
committee immediately and that's you
know something which we could do in
regard to this one as well
representative Myler thank you Mr chair
now that we have concluded uh our uh uh
our marathon here is it possible to have
uh uh Jen give us there was a form that
we used to get
that indicated all of the bills that
we've dealt with and it stated and their
respective status yes something like
that
the work path so we can all have a
chance to see that and yeah do that yeah
I'd like to see it too I haven't asked
her for one lately in the last month and
a half so now that we're done yeah that
works uh another comment for everybody
we now that we have gone through these
we do need to have all the uh committee
reports completed if you retain
something we don't need a convenient
committee report uh however it's OTP itl
no recommendation we need those reports
so you have report you need reports from
from just today yes yeah and there's a
few still coming in that I haven't
opened up anything here in the last
couple hours that may be a result of the
13th
uh of this month that I still don't have
we need to get all those in so we can
any other comments now another thing
which I I talked with representative
Cornell there about going down and
having a field trip
uh to you know to uh Hudson to look at
the Career Technical education center
down there and then making a stop here
in Concord on the way or on the way back
either way whatever fits in their
schedules and I think that'd be really
enlightening for people
Albert you're talking about and and Mr
Frog worth down there it used to be the
director of queer Tech education in the
state here and he's really on top of
things and and I have a lot of respect
for the the the Concord CTE Center too
it may be a little older but they have
some wonderful instruction going on in
that facility and I think you'd be
amazed to see what can be done Career
Technical education today it's just
fantastic I wish my own kids had gone
through this process and one of them
would have a job right now instead of
living off of Papa here
foreign
I just told a granddaughter last night
if you'd gone to the CTE Center just
across from Bradford you know how to fix
a compressor that way I wouldn't have to
buy a new one for your Volkswagen Beetle
and and that which is about two thousand
dollars for installation and all and
that's just you know not the time of the
year to be doing that
so so thank you very much everybody for
hanging there and 93 bills this is just
a marathon you've completed and we did
it well we finished on time there's
others not done yet with fewer bills
yeah
so as of I mean
now before all the Republicans hit the
road here we'd like to sit and talk for
a second about how we're going to handle
tomorrow I know the Democrats probably
that all designed and ready to go yeah
foreign